les chéris aujourd'hui le président
emmanuel macron était en déplacement à
nyon et c'est vrai il s'agit de la 20e
édition c'est un grand rendez vous des
professionnels de la restauration de
l'hôtellerie de l'alimentation sauf que
voilà alors que le président déambuler
dans les allées de rucks d'eurexpo
s'appelle comme ça le chef de l'état
était visé par un g dof oui il appelait
1,9 sur la tête alors on va voir l'image
la mesure n'est venu avec un avec la
seule sur l'épaule bonne image qui se
fait la vie dure garde sur la tête
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille essaimage
d'auge
il ya toujours une dame qui crient au
non
mais ça on ne rigole mais
désolé
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec le
président on peut être pas être d'accord
avec plein de choses mais là c'est un
manque de respect en plus je le dis
voilà en fait politique ici mais c'est
vrai que quand on compte on interpelle
il m'aime proton le relais entre un peu
de temps ils dialoguent nyala d'ailleurs
il a demandé d'ailleurs c'est maxi là
d'ici là un truc à me dire qu'ils
viennent et il a proposé seulement c'est
un jeune homme s'est créé en même temps
vive la révolution que tu vois le truc
se prend encore à l'époque que cuba
haulchin alors il s'est fait arrêté
juste après par la sécurité du président
et il a dit qu'il voulait juste faire
une omelette regarde
vous voyez un g2 tout de suite
interpellation pas facile ça va pas
comparable avec eux et pour ça je vous
ai dit c'est trop facile de le faire
mais moi ça m'interpelle
c'est facile moi je vais vous dire
j'avais j'avais interpellé le gie fleurs
de macron là je me suis fait des boîtes
et là pendant trois quatre jours sur les
réseaux sociaux alors je leur dit on et
menaces de mort ça vous pouvez continuer
je m'en bats les rangs total et je suis
juif maintenant sur ce choix sage juif
de
pimenter moi y'a beaucoup
[Rires]
j'avais 10 ans gifle aux invités vous
savez qu'ils abattent bocca
[Rires]
je le dis pour les gens qui n'ont rien
que ça passait pokora beach non mais ça
histoire j'ai reçu des menaces de mort
tous mois traité de vite parce que
jammeh dirige hydromassage hyper présent
les neuf c'est pas alors c'est vrai tu
es tu t'es pas moi mais les menaces de
mort
non mais un neuf il vise la tête il a
bien n'ont plus rien à redire encore une
fois c'est pas bien non plus et voilà
vous vous êtes en train d'entretenir un
truc qui va pas on jette pas des oeufs
sur le président
des crados là c'est vrai nom mais sur
personne et
récemment après la gifle il a remanié
son dispositif de sécurité autour de lui
d'accord il ya 70 personnes il a remanié
pour que ce soit un peu plus rapproché
mais il refuse de se bunkériser ils ont
pu l'essayer il refuse et c'est
compliqué aux états unis qu'il appelle
les rats le choix je pense qu'il faut
qu'il appelle là bas au début mais le
makhila j'avais à la levée au plus
les garanties au
pc de la maine ça va
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi la baie
géraldine on en rigole mais attend il ya
une promotion à la radicalité
aujourd'hui qui est super violente en
fait et moi je vois il a raison raymond
c'est à dire que quand il ya de vie
faire qui vient qui par année se kacou
kidiaba mais finalement je suis content
je regrette ma on a une vraie
responsabilité nous alors on va en
parler est alors celle là c'est pire
pardon
mais devenir d'accord
c'est pas ma paris mais on va pas dire
si c'est pire ou pas
oui et ça aurait pu être une boule de
pétanque pareil c'est ça qui est
dramatique mais
sans plus le souci c'est que le souci
c'est que ça veut dire que on veut on
veut me cherche même plus à dialoguer ou
même un relais en disant je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous et c'est là ce qu'on
veut c'est simplement faire un tube avec
la en humiliant les 11 ans qui ont ré en
respectant pas la fonction est par
ailleurs sana ça ne fait rien avancer
parce que enfin si si encore on était
venus interpeller le chef de l'état et à
ce moment là c'est tout le monde aurait
repris la discussion le dialogue y
compris l'invectivé mais la juste jeter
un oeuf ça dure deux secondes et demi on
dit c'est pas bien et on passe à autre
chose ces idées de
bernard montiel vous qui avez des infos
de l'intérieur le chef placé en garde à
vue ces violences sur personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique avec
préméditation donc tu to man file
portera non mais non mais il ne portera
pas plainte ce que je veux dire
simplement vous savez
c'est dur c'est d'y céder aux vidéos on
dit s'essaya que macron contre et mal on
a toujours maltraités les présidents
hollande a été en farine et valls il a
reçu une tarte il a été en farine et
aussi sarkozy pareil on lui a tiré le
bras etc il ya eu six mois de taule pour
le mec et jacques chirac en lui il ya un
mec s'approche de lui et qui lui dit
sale con et chirac lui répond et moi
c'est jacques chirac c'était assez
amusant jeu a l'air très sympa et oui
oui mais c'était bien sauf c'est
maintenant tout est filmé donc tous ces
gens là se médiatise avec ça et ça donne
une portée est ce que vous pensez nouvel
incident va réduire ses sorties pas du
tout ils aiment ça ils adorent ça et une
surprise vital a pas peur pour lui sans
rien parce qu'à un moment on commence à
peu flipper c'est vrai que là comme il
ya dix ans répète une boule de pétanque
sera peut être un autre chose cc c'est
compliqué évidemment qu'elle est
inquiète comme de chaque épouse doit
être inquiet de son mari quand il est
agressé c'est pas plus que les autres
présidents qu'on a non non en réalité
pas du tout ça quand on regarde tout ce
qui est arrivé moi j'ai fait un point là
sur le
nom mais tout six ans a été agressé
physiquement et ou 6 ans et à grand isle
à un quinquennat compliqué quand même
avec ces déçus la crise il a des gens ne
sont énervés après lui mais un truc très
simple en avril et mai on s'en fout de
ces audiences avril et mai atteindra les
élections aux audiences et
avril et mai y aura des élections tous
ceux qui veulent faire des révolutions
avec des yeux avec des gilets ou pas
nous prenons
va pas les mettre là dedans je crois que
oui mais moi j'ai tout à fait là on est
dans un pays on est dans une république
il a été élu au suffrage universel
président ça se respecte même si on
n'est pas d'accord avec ses idées il ya
je suis tout à fait d'accord etc si bien
dire c'est le moment c'est c'est le
bulletin de vote et ce sera en mai un
sur dix sont respectées le présent là
mais c'est lié la parole s'est libérée
les accès libre
voilà que c'est juste que il est où le
symbole quand c'est un citoyen qui perd
un oeil qui allie la différence c'est ça
robert rodriguez également sur qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça c'est sûr non
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya eu des violences
qu'il faut qu'il ya des gens qui ont une
sorte de de rejet physique des manuels
mâcon c'est peut-être ça la différence
avec ses prédécesseurs et donc c'est
vrai qu'à un déséquilibre nettement
japonais
pertinents je ne comprends pas ce qui a
eu des gens qui sont blessés et les
sanctions n'ont pas été à la hauteur
donc sacré al'inverse une radicalité
contre la personne du président face
j'entends ce que vous dites mais il faut
comprendre aussi la violence
mais il faut jamais légitimer
jeu complet mais sinon mais la violence
à cauterets bernard ville oui mais c'est
ça oui géraldine mais en moi je pense
que macro à tort il devrait porter
plainte pour le symbole pour l'exemple
de la même manière comment il ya des
insultes ou des menaces de mort sur les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il faut tout de suite les signaler
faut être exemplaire comme l'a fait
apple benayoun et je trouve que c'est un
tout petit peu d'impunité non mais c'est
pas grave non c'est grave il n'y a pas
de raison on est là en justice et après
on voit ce que ça donne mais vous mêmes
pour zemmour qui s'est fait insulter
aujourd'hui par le président sans danger
emmanuel macron on va voir donc voila
merci oui il ya 37 % de non à 63% voyez
moi je suis plutôt son respect pour les
gens des épiphénomènes